mit dem den kann man sich halt super
einfach mega starke automatischen
schusswaffen also wiener ak 740 oder
sowas bauen
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft galaxy tab
super team ist kommen ja immer noch sehr
viele fragen bei mir an
hey welches pack ist das eigentlich
stets war ganz oben in der beschreibung
aber okay ich gehe darauf revier unter
regel gerade drauf max ist übrigens auch
dabei hallo mama ich will marx hallo
auch an meine zuschauers ein herzliches
willkommen auf jeden fall
wir wollen heute produktiv sein und zwar
möchten wir uns heute unsere ersten
waffen bauen unser ziel wir wollen uns
eine ak-47 bank lieblings dann den tipp
dass wenn man ein grab schon ab dass
dann die sachen raus kommt auf jeden
fall sehr hilfreich ich muss mich auf
jeden fall auch jetzt erst mal um ersten
kümmern ich muss mal nach norbert hahn
nach meinen drachen auf steam soweit gut
geht
ich hoffe allerdings dass du deinen
drachen ernsthaft norbert genannt ich
schwöre er ist weg er ist einfach weg
das ist fies räder geklaut oder so das
war 100 vorträge in unserem team
ersetzen
er hat in meinen drachen weggenommen wie
unlustig ist das aber egal das ist schon
klären falls ihr wisst was war dann
müsste ich würde zu ihm sein oder so er
wird sich schon wieder finden ich finds
trotzdem voll doof dass das jemand macht
man es doch lustig aber aber dann kannst
du dich ja darum kümmern was wir in
dieser aufnahme machen wollen
richtig und zwar werde ich jetzt erstmal
auf die suche gehen
nach einer wüste wo ich mir ein bisschen
kakteen grün besorgen kann um dann halt
aus dem klassement
ich erkläre es von grund auf sag ich mal
man braucht um sich ein wappen crafting
table heißt das team glaube ich brauche
mal zu treffen braucht man sechs eisen
und wie viele waren es insgesamt ich
glaube drei kaktus screen oder ctis
green keine ahnung und mit dem den kann
man sich halt super einfach mega starke
automatischen schusswaffen also
irgendwie eine ak 740 oder sowas bauen
und das ist so krass stark und wir haben
es aber gedacht das müssen wir machen
weil das boxset mega wenn man mit so
einer schuld warum rennt und deshalb
mache ich jetzt immer auf die suche nach
so einem ding und ich verrecke gerade an
hunger ja das ist bei mir nicht auch so
eine sache ich brauche unbedingt was zu
fressen
und ich habe auch keinen kein eisen um
mir wasser einmal zu machen und mir
etwas anzupflanzen
das ist richtig doof ach scheiße weil
ich lebe ja in seinem blöden berg hier
drin und jetzt auch grad nacht und ich
will dich zweieinhalb herz sind nicht
nach draußen gehen könnte ich mich
könnte ich mich eigentlich in den mob
verwandeln und das sich nicht von den
eingegriffen werde oder die sonne geht
auf
das ist gut ich bin mir gar nicht sicher
zumal nicht ach du kannst da sehe ich
weiß also ich weiß ja man dann nicht
angegriffen wird
also dachte das war's jetzt nicht genau
aber ich weiß ich hab das glaub ich
gesehen in der folge von vom team und
stege da ist es sehr ärgerlich dass man
sich ja ich glaube steht wurde nicht
angegriffen als er als er in not gemacht
war ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher geht
jetzt nichts versprechen chemnitzerin
schon gesagt dass er als tintenfisch als
an land atmen kann
und er konnte es nicht er konnte nicht
atmen heilmann ertrinkt wenn man lange
als dem fischer und an land geht dann
ertrinkt von alter ist das ist stark max
einfach und manchmal gar nicht was ich
glaube ich glaube ich somit erstmal eine
höhle sich schon wieder an diesen
behinderten behindert behindert
ich brauche unbedingt was zu fressen ich
habe nur ein fleisch ich würde sagen ich
habe jetzt ein paar sachen gesammelt
ich komme zurück und dann dann kocht und
was schön ist falls ich zurückkommen
okay weil ich hab ich hier gerade ein
paar tiere getötet und eine fledermaus
ja fledermaus natürlich soll er soll
zurückkommen und und du du kochst an was
dafür ist wenn ich mich doch jetzt in
skelett verwandeln würde und das ist tag
ne ja krieg dann schaden region
verbremst und wenn ich jetzt einen
schicken bin kann ich dann einfach von
einem berg runter springen und sich fall
schaden kriege ich im dorf gefunden als
schicken
dies funktioniert auch auf jeden fall
bin ich mir ganz sicher aber so gehen
wir nur freunde hier runter alter wie
stark ist das denn das ist ja cool hier
ist es ist mega mega deal
das ist meine letzte richtig gerne auch
seine filme aus b dur akkord älter was
wir hier den gefunden so ein dorf mit
ganz viel kraft in sachen drin das
müssen wir markieren das dorf aber ich
bin immer noch auf der suche nach kaktus
screen habe schon viele sachen markiert
alters ist ein bisschen blöd als
schicken ich bin so ein bisschen langsam
irgendwie unterwegs ich gehe mal wieder
zurück in mich vom flaggschiff folgten
bittere genie war hier keine ahnung hier
so im wald wohnen werden die auch cool
er ist auf dem greifensee sich wenn er
bald durch harte winter aber ich glaube
so wenn ich bei mir zu hause bin so in
meinem werk dann fühle ich mich da
wundervoll wohl da freue ich mich schon
voll auf das dann so in meinem kleinen
oberster center der firma heißt immer im
livestream machen was bauen
nee ich kann ja nicht schlimm wenn man
im internet was stimmt ihr mann max ich
hab mein herz war ich komme jetzt zurück
okay ich fliege erst mal zurück und
bringen ihr was zu essen weil so macht
ihr die folgen jedoch keinen spaß wenn
du nichts zu fressen hast dann bringt
ihr etwas zu essen beim anbieter auf die
suche
also soll jetzt wieder zu mir nach hause
laufen also bis kein bitte zu hause ja
ich glaub jetzt wieder nach hause ok
dann fliege ich erst mal zu dir dachte
eigentlich ich treffe so ein paar coole
dinge die ich töten kann
aber da habe ich mir gedacht ich kein
politiker töten kann ich jetzt einfach
die schlag ist einfach gras kaputt und
versucht seinen namen zu bekommen das
stärkt das rieche strawberry sphären
ja man kann es den flugplatz und du
kannst hier sogar nutella brote machen
der ganze täler boote
das ist mega cool ja ok krass krieg
regel
ich habe immer noch kein kaktus grün
gefunden aber an die familien falsch
wenn ich irgendwo falsch und fühle mich
einfach tot
was bist du denn fürn braucht dann noch
einen schicken hier wird es zu langsam
die wie die laufen alle gleich schnell
glaubwürdig ach ja und auch gar nicht
finden weil ich allerdings welche hatte
ach ja okay jetzt schicken
okay okay ich bin auch da oben das wird
später richtig cool da oben jemand würde
ich meinen drachen geklaut bei mir noch
jemand so eine blöde nase daran gemalt
haben aus irgendwie naseweise nicht
sondern so ein stab irgendwie keine
ahnung
komisch okay ich hätte das britische ok
ich bin jetzt bei deinem haus luca ja
ich bin sofort so ich fange dann siehst
du dein fühlte mich nicht nur ein
bisschen was zu essen da ist mir 3,1 von
mir euch gerade eingepasst kommen jetzt
nach oben
töte mich nicht wenn ein hühnchen ok
mache ich nicht dann habe ich die
restlich noch ein bisschen was an essen
reingetan raw meat von astrid mannes
denn das kommen wir gar nicht hoch als
schicken alter das ist ja mal richtig
creepy ich hab dir toren die sachen
eingepackt in diesen kisten dass ich ein
bisschen was können ich nehme ein
bisschen proviant mit auf die reise
und da kann man loslegen ist hier in die
richtung irgendwann stand ich komme als
schicken da gar nicht hoch wo ich bin
meine eigene hauswand fast schon mal ein
spinne getötet weil dann könntest du die
wände hochlaufen
also man echt alle funktionen von den
mops kriegt man hinterher ich sonst
komme ich da nie hoch ich finde dass du
du widerruf des tiananmen drachen
geklaut hat es echt traurig und wir um
bringe niemanden töten
da ist auch richtig schwer zu bekommen
oder ja das war ein riesiges glück dass
ich den direkt am anfang gefunden habe
es ist einfach so effizient dass niemand
wegnehmen
aber ich meine hallo wo willst du
der war hier auf jeden fall wenn mir
gesagt dass es im postulat
ich bin bei mir die wo bist du bei mir
zu hause
ach so ich komme hier ich habe die
sachen schon eingepackt
wir wollen in mainz ja ok cool also in
den ofen und die kiste rechts und dann
habe ich es gepackt ist musst du jetzt
kochen
ohg eine menge drin du hast mein herz ja
das habe ich nur für dich mitgebracht
hab ich hier ich habe hier mein herz
geschenkt ja warum ist mir langsam an
die sachen setzen wenn ich dann hier
jetzt mein ganzes fressen hab dann geh
ich glaub ich meine höhle versuchen
ihnen die reisen zu holen
hallo aufladen los geht reisen holen ich
gehe jetzt nach einer höhle suchen nach
einer höhle nach der wüste suchen wo ich
mir die skeptische screen holen kann
müssen wir noch eine nacht abwarten dass
wir ein bisschen gunpowder kriegen von
krippen und dann sowieso weit bereit
dann kann es losgehen mein freund ich
weiß gar nicht wo soll ich denn hier
nach einer höhle sucht ja fast gar keine
höhlen gefunden
bei mir ist doch direkt die schlucht
dadurch waren bild schlucht du wirst du
bist eine richtige höhle nur wenn schon
anspruchsvollen zeiten schicken und
jetzt bin ich runter und ich kriege und
die freunde du das echt cool
die einzigste kacke ist die dadurch dass
es so mega viele bio gibt hier die einen
neuen zugefügt sind findet man die
klassischen biome nicht mehr also die
die man irgendwo man keine falschen als
jedermann die die man jetzt suchen würde
also wird zum beispiel ich gerade eine
wüste ich finde aber die ganze zeit
keine obwohl ich über die map liege aber
wir finden dass wir schauen nicht sag
mal so und mal so ein paar ärzte die so
cool sind die ich mir so holen sollte
cool heitz erste ich bin ich hatte also
das ist das ist halt alles dieses
automatische kräften und sowas
bieten wenn man das ziel dieses
automatisierte kräften dazu zählt es
alles was heißt ein automatisiertes
kräften dann kannst du dir irgendwelche
sachen packen und die die bauen sich
dann von selbst oder semi kakteen hat
nicht funktioniert mit den kopf ich
kenne ich die sachen halten nur so aus
dem megaprojekt und aus hero noch damals
so dass wir teil aber es gibt einige maz
die auch im mega projekt man also keine
ergebnisse sachen abbauen wenn du eine
vorstellung wann mal was mit technik zu
machen
immerhin alles später wir dann bei uns
ruhig melden und dann kannst du
irgendwann was darauf kräften
ich habe ich gerade 1 pechmann ich
fliege über die karte und finde einfach
keine wüste bei mir ruckelt das alles so
ein bisschen also die ich baue erzabt
die kommen so ein bisschen später darauf
was ist denn irgendwas grüne ist das zu
befahren ich habe irgendwas quantum und
nach der quantum mattes drauf nee ich
glaube man kann sich nicht die diese
hosen und sowas kräften dies gab also
ich habe glaube ich nachgeschaut die
kann ja damit mit dem quantum ott kann
man doch das ist doch pure kraft
keine ahnung du müsstest programm wendet
man sich also jemand hat einmal steht
glaube ich ja wenn du offen ihre windel
auch drauf ist auch seitdem steht er
auch welche mattes ist so durch dass du
dann herausfinden können was das für ein
ding ist ich habe gerade ein pech ich
finde einfach keine kakteen mega nervig
ich meine dann wird unser plan scheitern
wenn wir keine kakteen finden
es wäre total kacke ich dachte es wäre
viel leichter charakteren zu finden hier
in dem dummen minecraft du hast du ich
hab so viel eisen jetzt gerade
abgefahren einfach mal ja da er während
sein dass sie ärzte auch einfach alle
viel zu häufig auftreten
also sei er hier auch so dass da mal
richtig richtig viele er zum richtig
viele diamanten und so was alles war
also diamanten gibt es auf jeden fall
auch sei ich habe ja schon komplette die
rüstung ehrlich ich nicht
da keine rüstung verlust server valuten
sache candle in the wall
nein ich habe erhebliche verzögerung
folgerichtig fiel aluminium ab hier
meinen nachbarn gesehen weißem eine
spitzhacke ist kaputt und jetzt auch
oslo angeles kaputt ich bin mit in
seiner höhle felder
ich bin müssen echt etwas zu sehen wir
finden einfach keine sachen essen
ja wir sind voll die dummen irgendwie es
ist realistisch ab leider nicht erst
noch kein bett sich hingestellt
dann muss er sich mit dem bauernhaus
teleportiert ich frage mich echt mal
einen dritten einen drachen gesehen hat
irgendjemand wirklich jetzt die aufnahme
konfi während der aufnahme er irgend wer
hier wohnt in der höhle dahin bis und
fällt einfach oder warnung stuff drin
weiß sondern dungeon ja keine ahnung da
kommen wir wohl nicht dazu uns auch
heute so coole waffen zu machen
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht ist weil wir
einfach keine keine wüsten finden
ich würde auch sagen wie wir ende eben
ganz kurz die folge wenn wir schon auf
die 15 minuten zu gehen
nein dann würde ich sagen wir sind bei
13 minuten locker ja ich weiß aber ich
bin ende die folge weil regen in tron
alles möglich
ach so ja schon die letzten drei folgen
gemessen vorher schon so lange
aufgenommen ich hab nur die letzten drei
folgen schon länger gemacht und so
deswegen stimmt ich aber auch im jahr
dann würde ich sagen wollte wenn es
trotzdem gefallen hat und ich diesmal
auch nicht gestorben
dann zeigt es uns mit einer bewertung
und sonst will ich sagen ja nächste
folge versuchen wir dann irgendwie
charakter screen zu finden dass wir uns
in wattens box machen kann da kann man
es coole waffen machen und die sonne
gerade wieder unterricht sagen jetzt
beim nächsten gleich muss er auch vom
server runtergehen vergessen